so this is a book that's in some of the
schools in California Florida this is
not consistent with our standards called
gender queer I it's some of it's blacked
out you would not probably be able to
put this on air I have no doubt that
whatever clip I'm about to play of Ronda
santis is going to make total sense the
role of the school is to educate kids
not indoctrinate kids it's not to impose
an agenda it's to do the basics and what
we've said in Florida is it's
inappropriate to tell a kindergartener
uh that their gender is a choice it's
inappropriate to tell second grader that
they may have been born in the wrong
body now California has that uh they
want to have that injected into the
elementary school my wife and I have a
75 and a three-year-old we don't think
that that's appropriate I know most
parents do not think it's appropriate uh
it's also important to respect parental
rights to know what curriculum is being
used in the classroom and everything
should be age appropriate I actually
have something that I brought that some
parents have objected to so this is a
book that's in some of the schools in
California Florida this is not
consistent with our standards called
gender queer I it's some of it's blacked
out you would not probably be able to
put this on air this is pornography it's
cartoons it's aimed at children uh and
it's wrong so this should not be in
schools uh when people like on the left
say that somehow you're Banning books by
removing this from a young kid's
classroom no this is not age appropriate
and so we're going to stand for the
rights of parents I think we need to do
that Nationwide I don't think you can
have a situation where some states just
trample on the rights of parents parents
have a fundamental right to direct the
education and upbringing of their kids I
mean